DC Warner Brothers this is why you don't
rush into your big clashing of
superheros in your second film when you
take the time and build to it this is
what we get Captain America Civil War
this will not be a spoiler free review
I'm just gonna talk about the whole
thing I'm gonna jump around as I see fit
and I liked it I liked it a lot I am NOT
gonna declare it the best Marvel movie I
do think Winter Soldier is slightly
better but I gotta tell you when this
thing is good it's great and it's Sora's
I mean heck let's just jump to the
elephant in the room
the big climactic well not climax really
the story climax is a little bit later
but the fight that everybody is talking
about that everybody remembers at the
airport both sides going at it
Wow the powers them using their powers
to fight each other the way their powers
get countered by others the way that two
of them working together their powers
complement each other and it's so much
more interesting and it was fast at me I
didn't time it I have no idea how long
that scene was I have a feeling it was
pretty long but I was not bored for a
second of it because everybody's got
their own thing their own fighting style
their own power set and just to watch it
all get used so well it's it boggles the
mind how well put together that is so
let's touch on the new blood who shows
up in this spider-man Tom Holland I
think I'm gonna call it right now my
favorite on-screen iteration of
spider-man and I did not think that was
gonna happen I wasn't thrilled when the
cast as young as they did because I
figured that meant they were gonna go
for the high school awkward thing again
and while I do love the early spider-man
movies the spider-man 2 especially Tobey
Maguire never really worked for me
because he really emphasized that with
that performance the sad sack Peter
Parker the loser Peter Parker I never
fell in love with loser Peter Parker the
cons I kind of moved
that by the time I really started
reading this character then we had
Andrew Garfield who was very good when
he got to banter with them a stone and
he was good when he was in the soup but
when he was Peter Parker not with Emma
Stone he wasn't great it didn't quite
flow and they didn't seem to know what
to do with him this Peter Parker this
spider-man I loved him I loved his his
High sort of young energy how he's just
his his head is obviously going really
fast he's trying to keep up with it in
his mouth goes in you can tell it's a
nervous thing like suddenly he's Bandar
he's not being so cool and snarky it's
like he's nervous and he's got to do
something Julianne attention he's gonna
talk cannot wait to see more of him and
we also got our black panther chadwick
boseman nails this part black panther is
a badass and he's fascinating to watch
fight because he does have a really
unique fighting style with the way that
you know he does he doesn't punch he's
clawing at you and just really cat-like
in the movements which is a duh thing
because yeah Black Panther it would be
cat-like but they just visually pull
that off really really well and of
course all the returning characters do
really excellent work everybody knows
their character by now they all work
well with each other and the movie does
a really good job of giving an equal
validity to both what Tony is saying and
what Steve is saying both Iron Man and
cap they have got a valid viewpoint and
a valid reason for the position that
they've chosen to take and the movie
doesn't make well he's right he's wrong
which is nice because in the Civil War
comic Iron Man was really just a dick
and this one we really feel like you get
where he's coming from and while at the
very end in the climactic fighting yo
his emotions get the better of him up to
that point he's just he's making his
argument Steve's Maggie's argument
they're just neither of them is willing
to be the guy who compromises and
watching that come to a head in that big
fight is wonderful and actually in a way
it kind of works in the film's advantage
that nobody really wants to be fighting
that didn't work in Batman V Superman
because they were trying to actually
kill each
there and yet there wasn't really much
of a reason for them to be fighting this
time you know nobody wants to hurt any
of anybody one side is trying to achieve
something the other side is trying to
stop them but nobody wants to kill
anybody and it actually allows that
entire actions need to be much more fun
because while there are certainly stakes
they aren't life-and-death stakes so it
gets to be just thrilling and fun and
the spectacle of the whole thing the
movie makes its emotional climax after
that and in a way that's one of the few
criticisms I feel I can level at this
thing which is that the movie really
does peak with that Airport fight and
even as I was watching it there was a
part of my brain that went the movie
cannot possibly top this it will not be
better than this after the and it wasn't
now that's not to say it was bad after
that but it went that was the big chin
climax the emotional climax came after
even though we did still get a good
fight at the end and I also really kind
of liked the note that the movie ended
on where both sides was like look we're
not gonna reach an agreement on this
particular issue but if something comes
up that's bigger than this you know how
to reach me and you know what that works
I like it I think it was the right
hopeful note to end on given that the
team basically is decimated and
completely split apart at the end it
could have ended on a real down no and
I'm glad they chose to not do that you
know I'm not gonna sit here and keep
waxing the car of this movie it's great
I mean it really is great from start to
finish there's two other things that I
guess I could make slight complaints
about what is a qualified complain
that's with Zemo who is the villain
villain you know you Tony kind of serves
as the primary antagonist really but the
actual mustache holy bad guy is Zemo and
he's like many Marvel villains he's kind
of forgettable but I will say I really
like the way that they motivated him
which is that it's just simple basic
revenge very personal they didn't try
and make it big it's not some big global
scheme he's not part of Hydra you know
wheels turning within wheels got to take
over the world no he just wants to tear
apart this team cuz he blames them for
his law
and given how much characters personal
drives and personal motivations are
driving really the entire narrative in
the entire conflict having the villain
be driven by the same kind of thing was
a really smart decision so he functions
very well but just it is not
particularly memorable but that Manny
was never gonna be because the
interesting conflict is between Tony and
Steve and the one other complaint I'm
gonna make is and this is actually sort
of a praise by exception because you
know I singled out some characters I'm
not gonna single out every single
character because the characters are all
great everybody gets a wonderful
highlighted moment everybody gets you
know a bit where we really get you know
some really fun moments with the
character that you really feel why it
was important that they were around
except for Rhodey
except for Warmachine because unlike
every other character he's the only one
who just feels like hanger-on he's there
because Tony's there and really no other
reason I mean with Sam Wilson the Falcon
they made him feel like he has his own
agency Rudy
wrote he's just kind of their the
franchise's never really figured out
what to do with him ever since they gave
him the war machine armor and when he
gets clipped by vision and crashes that
felt kind of forced I was like okay okay
I mean it didn't it doesn't derail the
movie and it's actually a very large
praise of the film that for all the
characters it's got that there's really
only one of these heroes who gets the
short shrift
considering how many there are that's a
miracle so that's my thoughts on Captain
America Civil War I'm assuming if you're
watching the spoiler review you've seen
it so what were your thoughts on it
whatever they were drop something down
in the comments and let's talk about it
don't forget to Like subscribe check me
out on Twitter a council of geeks go
find the council of geeks podcasts on
iTunes and stitcher and until next time
this council is adjourned